this program is brought to you by Emory
University Sudan came into independence
with a Western model of a constitution
so that was sort of colonized by Britain
and from an Egypt but Britain was a
dominant partner so we ended up with an
English common law system of law with a
constitution that is based on the
European the way the British model of
parliamentary democracy but there was no
conviction in people so we had to go
through a process of really
experimenting with a variety a
single-party state I left his marxist
almost state and then an islamic
fundamentalist state and through those
experiences the people of Sudan have
come to realize that really that is not
the way to go but they are not clear
about which way to go the effort has
been in my part and many others who are
now in exile but very concerned about
what's happening in Sudan is to try to
build a national consensus not only on
what we don't want but what we do want
and I think values of pluralism of
acceptance of difference that is
religious difference cultural difference
a commitment democracy and
constitutional governance these are
values that people tend to intuitively
now begin to see are extremely valuable
for people of Sudan having through all
these tremendous upheavals and tragedies
let us learn the lesson and not just
simply go for simplistic solutions of
overthrowing regime establishing a new
constitution expecting everything to be
fine if the values are not there in the
popular consciousness their existence in
a document will not make a difference
the preceding program is copyrighted by
Emory University